it was an event to highlight violence
against women and girls a reception
hosted by Camilla the queen consort but
it's been totally overshadowed by the
encounter between Lady Susan Hussey and
ngozi falani the director of a charity
called sister space so there she said um
but where are you from I said we're
based in Hackney now where are you from
said I'm born here
no but were you really from and that's
when I thought okay this is turning into
something else yeah fulani's account of
the conversation shows lady Hussey asked
nine times where are you from where are
you from really and has he only stopped
asking when she came to the conclusion
wrongly that Fulani was Caribbean it's
front page news in the UK media
headlines describe it as a royal
disaster and use words including shame
and toxic lady Hussey is a central
support figure in the Royal household
having spent six decades as Queen
Elizabeth lady in waiting she's a close
friend of King Charles and his godmother
to Prince William
is currently in Boston the racism
railback home and unwelcome distraction
from his multi-million dollar Earth shot
environmental prizes which are being
announced on Friday
a statement from William spokesman said
racism has no place in our society the
comments were unacceptable it is right
that the individual has stepped aside
allegations of Royal racism have
previously been made though by Meghan
Markle the biracial wife of King Charles
other son Harry the claims made in a
2021 TV interview with Oprah Winfrey
contributed to a very public Rift
between Harry and the rest of the Royal
Family
ngozi falani stopped short of branding
Buckingham Palace as institutionally
racist but she says it's time to ask
serious questions for me having
encountered one person who has directly
been racist to me I can't say
How deep the problem goes I just know
that there's a problem and it's for
Buckingham Palace to do their own
investigations to find out how deep the
problem goes this is deeply
uncomfortable for Buckingham Palace King
Charles is head of the Commonwealth
whose member nations include many former
British colonies in Africa and although
lady Hussey's role most recently was
purely an honorary one she had risen to
become a senior member of the royal
household her attitudes towards race
clearly no obstacle to her becoming a
trusted Confidant of senior Royal
figures
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera London